Here is how I solved the problem.
I used an iOS class called NSURL, which comes with a function fileURLWithPath.
Now it turns out that this function does exactly what we want it to do.
It takes in a string and spits out an NSURL.
Now I can use this variable, which is of type NSURL,
in step two of our pseudocode, which is to create an instance of AVAudioPlayer.
Okay, I can create a new variable and call it audioPlayer.
And, then I can initialize it by calling the constructor for AVAudioPlayer.
And, as soon as I start typing it, Xcode gives me some suggestions.
Let me choose the one which takes in NSURL as an argument.
Let me hit Enter to accept the suggestion.
Okay, so this value here is the file path URL.
So let me replace that.
And error for now, I will enter as nil.
All right. So the last thing to do in our pseudocode is to play the audio.
To do this, I will go back to the action playSlowAudio.
Remember, this is the function that gets executed when we
press the button with the snail image on it.
And in here I will simply say audioPlayer.play().
Huh, it seems like there is a bug in our program.
It says use of unresolved identifier audioPlayer.
Can you check what to see what's going on here and help me solve this problem?
Here is your question one more time.
Enter your response in this box.